and next up here we got Japan's tachi
how versus New York Chris G so Tachikawa
rocking the near mullet haircut here yes
a jam dubbed it the Joe Dirt which I
could no longer unsee
yeah and I think we said yesterday too
if we said that to him he would probably
just say thank you and like smile yes
probably has no idea what Joe Dirt yeah
but he's rocking a new team he's no
longer rocking Frieza 18 or hits nah
he's rocking what was the GT I think is
on his team he has Yamcha teen gohan and
teen go on yeah what man is about that
winning a character selects free now but
talking about Frieza Chris G now playing
Frieza so at least we will get to see
the lord himself but this is definitely
a button check we know Chris G likes to
warm up his hands
I was gonna say if you ever seen Chris G
match you know the hand warmers are
coming up first and again he's the only
one I give a pass to because he plays 50
games and I believe yeah because this
isn't the regular Chris G team I believe
this is the regular Tachikawa team
though teen gohan yeah II collagen right
now and then Chris has been playing some
freezes I talked to him a little bit
about it after Mexico I think yeah after
after thunderstruck and he where he got
second overall
he was talking about just how Frieza
really helps him enjoy the game a lot
more he really likes playing the
character and that's what he's been
going with I believe it was use I was
saying he's one of the ones favorite to
kind of either win this tournament right
now yeah yeah the kill sage tweeted his
papers for the tournament our Christian
wha-wha
going into this I think wall wall was
the clear favorite of course he's and
losers bracket currently got put there
by nakiye Chris G also having tremendous
performances this year in Dragonball
fighters second at Thunder sure as I
said top eight at evil 2019 at the saga
event so we got a nice chunk of points
there but he's gonna get some more
points if he is able to get a top 8
winner sighs yeah we got the freeze of
the GT Goku and the Yamcha so yeah you
know both players rockin the GT Goku and
Yamcha in the second and third positions
but the Frieza for Chris G of course
[ __ ] Kalla has carried that Frieza flag
for a long time but has since put it to
the side and Chris G has picked it up I
told him to go bold in the field sever
to play freeze again and he goes no no
golden but like we've seen like I think
it was CEO that he had it come back
that was completely from his own soul of
Frieza left and he went golden Frieza
and smirking and it was like pretty
crazy from what I remember golden Frieza
my favorite stuff to watch in the game
it's great and if we're gonna see
somebody do it we're gonna see Christie
we were seeing him yesterday when he was
playing throw out the penis and charge
up those are yeah that's one of his
favorite strats for sure Greek air
already cool Chris you alright both
assists are down with Chris G second
one's about to come back up there do you
to go to being a great place to be
did hit
trying to keep his distance but get the
jump in talk to Karla taking freak to
the corner here yeah they say I like the
way Christians are playing these a very
heavy Frieza style just back up I think
I shot a low profile to be honest with
you based on that clip okay are we gonna
see another tag yeah we're gonna see a
snap in bringing Frieza back in here
tries to go for the overhead great
vanish out gets the super - in this
stuff from Christie so far now it's on a
set up shop staggering up the pressure
but why Chicago can hit the block waits
for the disc coming back there we go now
he pulls other up like this time by a
little super that you see them
simultaneous across up super - in this
extension this is a good place for
Christie to be sitting here drops upon
go-go begins that punish on that snap or
the tagging oh you have held the Vantage
so he can get the pool combo I think
that freezes classic oh it doesn't drop
this he's gonna have no but he dropped
it I curse them that skirt right there
oh there's a little 3d recovering time
don't eat that not at that dad Frieza
Tachi towel we saw him defeat Koopa
yesterday as well with that Yamcha
reversal level 3 you gotta watch out for
it Pence's if just backs off afterwards
yeah I'm surprised there's no for the
conversion off that GT Bell who says
maybe he wasn't expecting it you know oh
great
forward advancing there to get in they
would have the Optus is extension if he
wants it okay right just keep it on deck
for the post you can keep out my mixup
it just feels like it goes so far yeah
man the yucca Katara
yeah they got that hot sauce it is gold
you yeah there it is okay great new city
on posters finally hit the low here [ __ ]
taller and good positioning still
waiting for the assist to come back up
but snaps out Rincon Yamcha goes below
this is building time to get those
assists back finally gets the Yamcha
those block the empty low here but he
got block one more time and the burial a
overhead connection snaps him out again
force him to play with one carriage and
force on the spark
I like the switch to low they're
thinking that maybe he was gonna expect
him to overhead falls out the gap there
it goes right into that level three
so this is a alright for Christy because
it's gonna be all blue life prices in
our look you'd be able to heal all of it
via the sparking I like the way that
Christy was able to avoid the on census
there but gets the will think this gets
us hit this is gonna be a good spot for
him
spirit ball should do it they slowed
that down but still catching Tasha cow
or they'd be able to get that power
double Warren powered up level one with
the Amish at level one good place to be
and just like that the tables are pretty
much evened up here both still have the
Ianto cysts on each team you know when
they plan on using it greatest sister
halves don't one of the best in the game
my opinion almost definitely and yeah
just little point character as well we
see taka talla
and finally a raw tag them out now one
of the things I noticed in the way that
that the Japanese players early at least
watch Okawa plays teen gohan versus the
way the American players plan is taka
Khalid not really using and abusing the
auto combo Yeah right he hasn't been
swinging for the fences like we see a
lot of the teen gohan players do CV
given the opportunity if you take say
late goes right into the entree in some
air - oh we're just catching Chris G
cutting life yeah
go for it we will take fists here she's
gonna get the knockdown off of this he's
gonna go for the jump in no go spring
for dragon rush great in front of I yeah
I can tell if those the start up over
reflect or not but either way it does
connect and Chris Jesus at GT go through
his dead but man he is pretty clutch on
this solo Yongchun he's got seven bars
Hachiko it doesn't have a lot of life
and a great age whooping fist to start
the game level 1 into level 3 I think is
actually gonna kill here oh yeah bring
them close oh yes Chris G's successful
this is good you know good job for Chris
G to make that conversion and still
spend that and clean his plate there
and now we have the light fleet on top
scholar and they both have equal amounts
of meter here all right throwing out the
key blasts try super - in puts himself
cancels out team Gohan was above his
head behind Yamcha and the spinning
mixer still got the hitbox on that he
spins around dogs 360
Wow yeah if you're touching Cowell you
got to make sure you don't get mentally
cracked over something like that right
you were so close to winning the first
game very unfortunate way to play out
for him leave
Eric in from Chris she definitely
started the last game he's gonna get
more of a combo this time off of it
though a tomato you could say free
rabbit
y-you might say that all right we're
stepping out we're going in here Frieza
trying to stagger some of these hips
here try to get that opening the peace
of this route gets the low off that goes
right into the heavy note I'm telling
maybe trying to reflect there you had a
block crouching so he comes back wow I
just really like what I'm seeing with
Chris cheese fries especially like in
the corner just keeping that pressure
but dust back off there gets hit by the
key blacks from team go on more lock it
in the corner but you didn't actually
make them block after the combo and
there's a Christian great here - as well
curry actions on this man have always
been so good I like to reflect on that
last set of the legs and main box a big
jump all the way to the corner again I
mean to be fair that is like Lord Frieza
ship right behind there right right
right home court advantage
excuse me out the disc in now just
waiting for the rods and flutters is
perfectly and gets the level three after
the Destructo this football Krissy how
you always so ready he was ready maybe
it's that Marvel experience the Marvel
brain he definitely does his brain
excels at games like this he's able to
take down the GT Goku went from when
wind man
when's Dragonball yeah alright young
peasants down there Tata Paulo finds the
hit go off that chump we're gonna knock
down we're gonna change in the wulfing
fist
here we go spending the three bars but
Christie sought that time he texted he
was looking for the if it's not broke
don't fix it strap but Christie with a
quick adjustment let them lock down with
a yawn so there hope you go through this
is available for the yeah in Scenario -
makes up for a tech afterwards Chris G
just seen Hachi collar trying to get out
reporter there this has been so patient
this game and then guess the super - is
he calls the obtrusive gets both gonna
do a lot of damage here oh so smart
those are to the level three four freeze
that because it's one hit right so he's
gonna get the max damage on gone shake
even if the point character dies quick
man you smart
this man has unlocked his potential and
then again any car goes off the
apostle's barking you cannot press bugs
on the destruct oh this is my friend
Chris G topic winner side yeah got
sucked into the vacuum of space right
there maybe this will make Tots maybe
this is revenge right now for tachi Kawa
giving up on Lord Frieza I gotta say you
know I wonder how thought Chicago feels
about that right dropping the Frieza
dropped from the Android 18 picking up
the cheaper characters a more overall
talk to your team and then Falls to
Chris G's Frieza
man I like that story